i am a 20 year old female living at home
since the pandemic with my parents
younger brother who was a decade younger
than me wait i'm confused already
she is a 22 year old female oh she is
she doesn't have a 20 year old no she
i am a 22 year old female living at home
since the pandemic with my parents
and younger brother who was a decade
younger than me she's 12.
yes unlike me great math unlike me who
grew up
shy and obedient to my parents my
brother is a complete brat
uh my old-ass parents don't give a [ __ ]
because well they're
old now and look at me to help raising
him essentially because
it's like a lost cause i tried being his
friend i tried being the older sister
but nothing works
he's still a piece of [ __ ] it's causing
me to have poor anger management and
rage that makes me want to hit him
though i never want to do that to him
the way my parents hit me growing up
i hate to admit it but i'm starting to
hate him and even resent my parents for
having this accident baby
yet these feelings make me feel really
guilty the bottom line is how do i go
about treating my younger brother
should i attempt to build a better
relationship even though it's hard or
should i preserve my own mental health
and hold on until the pandemic ends and
escape this nest completely
which will make me which will be better
when he's older you already know burgess
that he hates boys
yeah oh no by the way i'm having the
same problem with my daughter except
it's not my brother
she's like yeah i resent her i want to
hit her i can't wait till this
pandemic's over i can get the [ __ ] out
i look at my wife sometimes who is so
[ __ ] good of a person
so good man she sees everything with
love
i wish i could be that person i get
bitter and angry about certain things
like what was that i'll give you a
perfect example um
did it happen today or it happened
yesterday it was i was like
oh last night the girls took the bikes
out but then they just left them all
over the backyard
and i was like hey guys we're gonna put
the bikes away
and they're like what and i said georgia
we're putting the bikes away and she's
like what do you want and i was like
no you hear me you don't want to do it
and then i got really angry and then she
was like i didn't take him out and i was
like
that's not what i said i didn't say hey
did you take him out can you help me i
said
we're going to put the bikes away she
was like isla and then i'm like
why are you doing this like why are you
and then my wife's like
and and then they go outside and i go i
don't like that disrespectful [ __ ]
she's a kid let her who gives a [ __ ] and
i was like no but
she should be she goes did you do that
[ __ ] to your dad and i was like yeah
and i was like wait how can you be so in
the moment kind of positive
like don't you want to [ __ ] throw her
in the pool or something she was like
she was like you need to calm the [ __ ]
down and i was like and then i start
spinning out of control and i'm like no
one tells me to calm the [ __ ] down
and i'm like and i go and but it's so
funny that like
i know what that girl's going through
yeah is there is a
weird selfishness where we forget
what it would be like to be her little
brother
and it's and and sometimes the rules
were different from us
for us when we were growing up like i
told my daughter the other day i go
we were talking about tattoos and i said
you can never get a tattoo
and she was like well that's not a rule
and i went no it's definitely a rule
and then i went and then and then i said
i don't have a tattoo she goes
i don't care she goes do you know why i
don't have a tattoo she goes why do you
have a tattoo dad and i go because my
dad said i couldn't get a tattoo and
that's why i don't have one and that's
why you're not getting one
our dad my dad said we can't get one
like what the [ __ ] world am i living in
oh i don't give a [ __ ] if she has a
tattoo i do reverse psychology
with jewels with a teenager we have here
i'm like you should get a tattoo every
day get a tattoo
bobby's like hey do cocaine do cocaine
do all this
she couldn't be a more angelic child
like we just keep forcing her into these
what we think and she's like oh that's
so like
uncool and like your age stuff
she comes up with a face tattoo right
now hiya hello hello i did it
i i got really high on cocaine and i got
a face tattoo
bobby's gonna be so happy you guys love
me more now guys i'm pregnant
so what do we tell this girl to do um i
think those feelings are
super normal i think everyone in the
pandemic in the same household wants to
uh murder each other yeah just hang in
there
and when you do get the time and the
money and
yeah get out of there get your own place
have that independence
what you're saying is so i didn't mean
to cut you off i'm sorry but what you're
saying is so
real she's forgetting she's in a
pandemic a little bit
and that if the ev my wife says it to me
over and over again
you're dealing with you're in a pandemic
you can't go out and work you can't like
other than what i did a little bit but
like
she's like you can't go out to the store
you can't go out to dinner
you can't go to pat's to have a cocktail
you can't do that
and don't forget that you can't do any
of that [ __ ] and then she can't do any
of this [ __ ]
and you're the reason she can't do any
of this [ __ ] because you're saying if i
can't do this [ __ ] you're not doing this
[ __ ]
and then all of a sudden that's all real
tension in a household
that is because we're in a very unique
time and
and to forget we're in a unique time is
is almost to to blame yourself for
something you're not guilty of
yeah those feelings are very real
they're very valid but
don't blame yourself for having them
it's a pandemic if you guys were out of
the house
you would if you were out of the house
you'd come in you'd see your brother
you'd smile and go
hey what are the [ __ ] old [ __ ] up to
today and you'd be like oh
they're [ __ ] they hit me and you'd be
like ah sit down but they're not hitting
him
because you're all in the same house
they can't just start beating them up
now
it's [ __ ] awkward beat the [ __ ] out
of him in front of everyone
i would just walk around with like
nunchucks and like [ __ ] like
you know what do you call those things
knuckles
and just like look like i'm training for
a [ __ ]
i look like i'm training for a kumite so
that the younger 12 year old is like
what the [ __ ] is she up to
so he just gets in line here's what you
do while he's sleeping
cut his hair just a little bit a little
bit
so you know you [ __ ] won and then the
next morning go hey man your hair looks
good and it'd be like
and then you always have that knowledge
that you won
just a little locket of hair and then
leave it places
and be like put it in this food and
they'll be like who's hair in my food
and go you sure it's not your hair
i hope that helped you friend yeah i
hope that helped you thank you so much
for
doing this bert hey thank you for having
me i really like you this was a blast
and we're going to go spearfish we're
going to live out the hawaii dream i'm
a 100 into all of that anything to
promote anything
i uh i don't have anything to oh no i'm
sorry i have a tv show uh
tbs go big show every uh thursday night
9 p.m
8 central uh the finale is coming up
it's a two hour i think it's an hour for
an hour
i don't know whatever but it's a good
show it's a big family friendly fun
thing snoop dogg's on it cody rhodes
jennifer nettles rosario dawson
and myself i'm hosting and